scott kelly
spent
340 consecutive days out in space you
analyzed his molecular data dna rna
proteins small molecules what did you
learn about the effect of space on the
human body
from scott we learned that spaces is
rough on the human body but
that the human body is
amazingly and
monstrously responsive to adapt to that
challenge it can rise to the occasion so
we could see there scott had as almost
all astronauts do a bit of puffiness and
spikes in his bloodstream of these are
called cytokines or these inflammation
markers or the body is clearly
saying to itself holy crap i'm in space
and
liters of fluid move to the upper torso
and they get puffy face what's called
the in the astronaut face that is very
common but it goes away after a few days
and some astronauts maintain high levels
of stress for their whole mission as
measured by cortisol or some of these
other inflammation markers whereas scott
actually had a little spike but then he
was cool as a cucumber for most of the
mission
but he had spent at that time that was
the longest ever mission for a u.s
astronaut a few cosmonauts have gone a
little bit longer but there'd never been
a deep molecular analysis of what
happens the body after about a year in
space so it was the first study of this
kind
and what we found is when he got back
you know we saw all the same markers of
stress on the body and changes spiked up
to levels we've never seen for any other
astronaut before so it seemed like
going to space for a year wasn't so hard
as much as returning to gravity after a
year it was much harder on the body
uh he notoriously had you know broke out
in a rash all over his body
and really even the weight of clothing
on his skin was too heavy it created all
this irritation because his body had not
felt the weight of just a simple t-shirt
it was it wasn't really had zero weight
of course right so and up in space
so that led to all this inflammation all
these changes he had to you know
it was much more comfortable just to
walk around nude in that case it was for
medical reasons some people do this you
know recreationally he was doing it for
medical purposes i do it for medical i
mean
strengthening all the time i mean people
say a prescription since the doctor told
me
so he was allergic to earth yeah it's
fascinating to think about actually how
quick did his body adapt there so there
was about three to four days he got back
to normal at least in terms of the
inflammation but what's extraordinary is
that
we measured a lot of other molecules
genes
structural changes tissue looked at his
eyeballs like his vasculature it took
him even six months after the mission a
lot of the genes that had become
activated in response to space flight
were still active so things like we
could see his body repairing dna he was
being irradiated by cosmic rays and by
the radiation it's the equivalent of
giving it like three or four chest
x-rays every day just in space and we
could see his body working hard at the
molecular level to repair itself and
even in his urine we could see bits of
what's called eight oxyguanazine is a
form of damage dna that you could see
coming out
and we see it for other astronauts as
well so it's very common you can see
damaged dna the response of the body to
repair the dna but even though he'd been
back on earth for six months that was
still happening uh even six months
wait
later
do you explain that so some of this has
to do with when you have a gene get
activated you might think oh it's like a
light switch i'll look at my wall just
flip a light on or off and sometimes
turning a gene on or off is that simple
sometimes you just flip it on because
the gene is already ready to go other
cases though you have to reprogram even
the structure of how your dna is
packaged yeah which is called an
epigenetic rearrangement in that case we
could see it is that a lot of these
genes had been
these cells had changed the structure of
how dna was packaged and it remained
open even months after the mission now
after about a year it was actually
almost all back to normal 99 of all the
genes were back to where they were in
pre-flight levels so it means that
eventually you'll adapt but there
there's almost a a lag time kind of like
jet lag for the body but jet lag for
your cells to repair all the dna what
was the most surprising
thing that you found in that study there
are several surprises one is just that
he
that the rep as i just mentioned that
the repair took so long i thought maybe
a week or a few days he'll be back to
normal but to see this molecular echo in
his cells of his time in space still
occurring was interesting this telomeres
was one was really surprising the the
caps on the ends of your chromosomes
which keep all your dna packaged and you
could half your chromosomes from your
mother and half from your father and
then you'd go on and make all your cells
normally these shrink as you get older
and telomeres just length is just an
overall sign of aging getting shorter
his telomeres got longer in space
and so this is really surprising because
we thought the opposite would happen so
he that was genetically once suppressed
and also some of the mutations we found
in his blood he had less mutations in
blood as if his body was almost being
like a low dose of radiation was sort of
cleansing his body of maybe the cells
that were about to die is one of our
main theories on what's happening
and of course you can't really you have
theories but you can't
because
the number of subjects in the study is
small right it's the it's notoriously
one of the lowest powered studies in
human history yes but but but what you
will you lack in subjects you can make
up for in the number of sampling time so
we did basically 260 samples collected
over the course of three years so we
really almost every few weeks had a full
workup uh including in space so that was
the way we tried to make up for it but
we but we've tried another model
organisms in mice we've seen this we've
looked now in 59 other astronauts and in
every astronaut that we've looked at
their telomeres get longer in space
does that indicate anything about
lifespan all those kinds of things or no
you can't make any of those kinds of
jobs yes i won't make that jump yet but
it does indicate that there is a version
of
cleansing if you will that's happening
in space a mixture of we see this
actually clinically at our hospital you
can do a low dose of radiation with some
targeted therapies to kind of activate
your immune cells is even even tried
clinically so this idea of just a little
bit of stress on the body or what's
called hormesis might prime you into
active of cleansing things that were
about to die